the aviation and aerospace industry
comes back into focus this week as the
2022 edition of the ila air show opens
in berlin
while the central topic of the show will
be the development of the sector in 20
years it's present and near future
prospects are riddled with uncertainty
the russian invasion of ukraine has
slowed the post-pandemic recovery of the
industry on a global level but while
international airlines have been
minimally affected harsh sanctions and
isolation have hit russian airlines the
hardest impacting both cargo and
passenger traffic
russian airlines are currently banned
from flying to most countries in europe
and america since the start of the war
due to the sanctions companies like
error flood or s7 cannot receive spare
parts and updated service manuals from
companies like airbus
boeing or other western suppliers
raising worries about the long-term
safety of the russian commercial and
cargo fleets
for more on the state of the russian
aviation sector i'm now joined by
stephen wright he's an industry
professor specializing in aircraft
engineering at tempura university in
finland welcome to dw steven
the european union aviation
safety agency says it is very worried
about the state of western made aircraft
flying in russia do you agree
yes i do actually i think that uh
iasa has made a very good judgment call
understanding that aircraft all aircraft
need maintenance that's done to a
specific standard
and if aircraft are operated outside of
those standards
then this is a safety issue
let's take a look at russia's maybe most
prominent carry here aeroflot out of its
187 planes all but 10 are made by airbus
and boeing which cannot service these
aircraft anymore
what does that mean how do you keep
these planes
ready to fly
that's a really interesting um
question and a big problem for anybody
operating in an isolated area
um effectively what they have to do is
uh try to find parts from somewhere and
that's a massive problem at the moment
because all aircraft stuff goes wrong on
them all the time so you replace the
parts that don't work
and
the problem with russia at the moment is
they're not legally allowed to buy any
spares from anywhere so where do they
get the bits even if they were able to
take the boxes off the parts off and fix
them themselves
the paperwork will be incomplete because
it will be maintained and done by stuff
that's just not recognized and this has
a massive effect
on the whole of
the aircraft industry
so
basically you're saying even if
people in the russian aviation industry
are able to fix the problem right now it
could mean trouble down the road
massive problems for instance this plane
these planes these 500 planes that are
being
quarantined in russia
none of the paperwork is now going to be
compliant so all the paperworks
um is held by the lease or so these are
the russian airlines
and if the paperwork's not complete at
the end of the lease
you you've really struggle to give the
aircraft back to the bank
and then the next person that rents the
aircraft leases the aircraft they're not
going to be able to lease it because the
paperwork's going to be incomplete stuff
will be done that hasn't been done in
accordance with the arsa laws that's why
aviation's so safe
everything is so well controlled there
are no deviations
aviation has a strong history in russia
what sort of future do you see for the
sector uh in the country
well this is going to have a massive
knock-on effect because effectively
who which bank is going to want to lease
102 million
u.s dollar asset to a country
when they know that they might not ever
see their asset come back at the end of
it once the lease is finished
so where are they going to get the
planes in the future i mean it's a
massive problem
stephen wright aeronautics professor at
tampere university
in finland stephen thank you for your
time
thank you
and staying with the aviation sector
past lockdown travel enthusiasm among
people here in europe could be seriously
tainted this summer
due to a serious staff shortage at
airports a reporter went to dusseldorf
in the west of germany to gauge the mood
among employees and travelers
the departures hall at dusseldorf
airport
passengers going through security
screening have to be patient
it can take more than four hours
scenes like this have occurred often in
recent weeks causing hundreds to miss
their flights
i'll be disappointed
very disappointed
because
because i paid money so i'd like my
services to be
fulfilled
my neighbor works at the airport and he
said it was because a lack of security
personnel and that's stupid you pay a
lot of money for your flight so it's
annoying if you miss it especially since
they laid off security staff during the
pandemic
a spokesperson for the german aviation
association says the chaos at german
airports is unfortunate but little could
have been done to prevent it
the coronavirus pandemic has presented
the industry with major economic
challenges
unfortunately staff reductions were
necessary
some of them found jobs in other sectors
at the same time after two years of the
pandemic demand for flights has soared
and kovid 19 restrictions were suddenly
lifted so it wasn't possible to plan
properly for the relaunch
jose tarim has a different view
the aviation expert advises members of
the verdict trade union who work for
security at dusseldorf airport
the state is ultimately responsible for
this task but puts it in the hands of
private security companies and of course
they want to earn money they're not
social organizations and how can you cut
costs by keeping staff levels low we
have a serious staff shortage especially
in passenger screening
all passengers have to pass through
security not enough people were hired so
now you're seeing the results
one major problem is that anybody
working at the security screening or on
the apron has to be trustworthy
the required background checks take at
least six weeks usually longer
so it's not possible to simply hire
extra staff
it's a problem with dramatic
consequences as a security screening
employee at a german airport explains
he wants to remain anonymous
you see the huge crowds of people in the
terminals at some point it's not
possible to keep up like when we have to
take a break
that isn't always given to us by the
federal police or our employer
they just want to keep passengers
flowing through security
and then air safety is no longer
guaranteed
meanwhile germany's leading airline
lufthansa blames sluggish ground
handling for the recent cancellation of
almost a thousand flights
anybody hoping to fly in the coming
weeks will need to be patient